biden warning of real food shortages uh
food shortage risk over russia's
invasion into ukraine we've been hearing
murmurs about this but it's very obvious
ukraine is the breadbasket of europe
they produce wheat russia exports
fertilizer we're no longer able to buy
that fertilizer for the most part the
prices are skyrocketing which means the
spring planting season will be limited
and that also means the fall harvest
will be severely stunted so you can
expect to see food shortages here and in
europe and biden is warning about it
i think
there's a couple things to point out one
is
that biden has basically said we're
gonna what did he say we're gonna
disseminate food shortages around the
world yeah what a ridiculous thing to
say sounds like a biden thing to say
yeah but you know people will be like
what he really meant was we're gonna
disseminate food around the world well
you don't know what he meant he said
he's going to make food shortages worse
the other thing is this is the direct
result
of a lack of culture coming from the
right because politics is downstream
from culture as andrew breitbart said
and when you get
a 2020 in which every channel every
movie every media outlet is all
screaming orange man bad it lights
people up to get out there and
i i always bring up the story man people
i know who have no business in politics
i certainly think they have a right to
be but these are people who couldn't
tell you what the supreme court was how
many justices it has or even name a
single member of congress going out and
voting why
because their media and their culture
tells them what to do
now we're seeing the ramifications of
this joe biden as president is not
responsible for every crisis we're
dealing with but he's certainly a bad
leader who said he's going to be
disseminating food shortages
now we get to experience those food
shortages
because to stop literal hitler you would
elect anyone yep
it looks like the actual quote is uh we
both talked about how we could increase
and disseminate more rapidly food
shortages
[Laughter]
it's a great quote that's our biden
no just makes it just makes me
contemplate time you know
the passage that's the passage of time
what is that imagine are we seeing this
situation five years ago like yeah we're
gonna have these food shortages and the
president's gonna go he's gonna
distribute the food shortages
um imagine being donald trump speaking
at a rally and saying if you vote for
joe biden you're going to have your gas
prices are going to go way up the
economy is going to be bad and you get
freaking fact-checked and shut down on
facebook for saying it probably at the
time yeah missing context they would
have said oh yeah yeah no for sure i
remember this one fact checker
someone quote tweeted me because i
talked about bill clinton epstein's
plane
and they fact checked it as false when
you click the fact check it's explained
in great detail how i was correct yeah
they it's it's the most insane thing
they did it to josh hawley uh politifact
did it where they're like josh hawley
says that you know judge jackson was
lenient to let's just say child abusers
very extreme child abusers and they're
like mostly false and then you scroll
down it's like well it's true she was
lenient to these people it isn't a a uh
it isn't out of the ordinary for judges
to be lenient and it's like did he say
it wasn't he just gave a fact
so well this is the reality of where
you're at when your cultural
institutions are dominated by a cult and
by people who are are intent on just
controlling the system even even if it
means bringing it to the ground yeah the
institutions in this country were always
the real bulwark against uh state and
corrosion
state intrusion into our lives right you
had the states actually created the
federal government so that they're like
the ultimate pre-federal institution you
had the church which was one of the most
important institutions in the country
you had other institutions though
corporate america i think the
probably the the
it's unpleasant to say but like probably
the institution that mattered the most
in many ways
as a bulwark against state power you had
uh the family the ultimate institution
and
what the left has done over the since
the 60s is they've infiltrated every one
of those institutions
since the state automatically
essentially desires what the left
desires
a state
the natural state of a state is to grow
its power over the individual
which is a which is a left-wing goal
since that is the truth when when the
left takes over all the institutions
that allowed
uh the the people to
essentially it solves the collective
action problem of the people in
defending their rights against the state
once once the institutions are on the
left the institutions immediately
essentially become
an arm of the state and you see that
with all these fact checkers you know i
actually i have a soft spot for for
facebook i mean daily wire has been the
number one publisher in the world on
facebook 15 months in a row wow
we do really well on facebook i think
mark zuckerberg if you were to talk to
him personally
wouldn't see himself as a guy who has
taken voices away from so many people he
would see himself as the guy who's given
a voice to a billion people
nevertheless the institution that he's
created because you know 30 000 people
at facebook all walk in lockstep uh with
the left they've become an arm of the
state and so instead of corporate
america now it's all the things we've
been talking about all night hr and all
these things instead of corporate
america solving the collective issue the
collective um uh action problem of the
individual they actually become a part
of the state's power to set to shut down
the individual that's why you get these
incredibly orwellian expressions like
fact checking
how can you have a fact check that says
you are mostly
false that something is mostly false
which is completely true
and what the answer is that missing
context or mostly false the piece that
they say was missing or
that would have
that created the falsehood is just their
point of view not more information not
more fact their point of view missing
context if i say joe biden isn't a good
president you know they will say uh fact
check mostly false missing context and
you'll read the article and they'll say
well
hyperinflation
uh war overseas the end of american
hegemony gas prices through the roof
food shortage food shortages of being
disseminated around the globe but other
presidents have been bad
they would say joe biden actually
promised to disseminate those food
shortages so he's keeping his campaign
promises he's a good president let me
ask you we've had we've had a few people
on the show we recently had a more
middle of the road guy on the show and
uh sometimes we hear this from the from
the moderates that you know oh the both
sides things i think both sides have
their problems or whatever my response
to this is like look man i i personally
have never been the staunch conservative
guy i've actually when i was younger i
went to catholic school up until i was
in sixth grade then i went like anarcho
punk rock hang out with these hardcore
like lefties and then eventually i just
found a middle of the road place
but
when you have
i love going through the list of stories
covington kids russiagate ukraine gates
jesse smallett uh michael brown trayvon
martin lie lie lie lie lie over and over
again at a certain point why aren't
these people being like i was lied to i
shouldn't listen anymore you know you've
got these fact checkers who come out and
they fact check stories that later turn
out like the hunter biden laptop
all the fact checkers later turned out
to be
always true
they always knew that it was true so how
like what's your view on this look i
talk about i call it a cult all the time
we call this we call them the city urban
liberal types sorry uh people living in
cities but you're the cult and uh
what are your thoughts on this why are
they faking it are they lying are they
just stupid i agree that it's a cult uh
to some degree i mean the it looks like
a cult if it looks like a cult right and
smells like a cult but i think that
andrew klavan talks about this from time
to time i i'm loathe to agree with
andrew clavin on anything
but on just this one thing he he did
christen me the god king so on these two
things i agree with andrew
everything we're living through right
now
is because we as a species
have not evolved
to under to know what to do with the
internet
you know the the protestant reformation
in many ways was a reaction
to the advent of the printing press that
it seems funny to us so far down the
road from the printing press the
printing press was such a remarkable
leap forward in technology for human
beings suddenly there was information
available to everyone that formerly had
only been available to the very very
elite few
and
to come to grips with that
took two generations and a war that pro
that wiped out millions of people in
europe like
that ripped the church asunder that
ripped the world order asunder
they printed words on paper and the
protestant reformation happened
basically as a result and it's always
that way when you have these moments of
you know in many ways uh world war one
was a reaction to the industrial
revolution when there's these enormous
leaps forward in technology people don't
know what to do with it it takes a
generation or two
the the internet
literally rewires our brains it has it
has biological uh uh
ramifications we have so much
information more information than any
human being knows what to do with we
have not solved how to take in all that
information how to sort through all of
that information how to come to
conclusions and so what we've done
is we've the same thing we did when the
printing press happened we've just
become more tribal since i can't sort
through all the information i have to
believe that tim knows how to sort
through the information i have to
believe that jordan peterson knows how
to sort through the information i have
to believe that ben shapiro knows how to
sort through the information i have to
believe and the problem with that is
some of the sorters are better than
others
i was wondering uh you know joe biden
recently came out and said uh he he uh
referenced the fourth turn the fourth
turning the stras how generational
theory are you're familiar i imagine he
said you know between 1900 1946 you know
what do you say 60 million people died
yeah then there was a liberal world
order there will be a new world order i
was wondering we talked a bit about how
we brought that up but i thought to
myself why was it that so many people
died between 1900 and 1946 you know what
was the catalyst for these emergent
ideologies that opposed each other so so
fiercely and i wonder if it was radio
all of a sudden we got time serialized
radio programs radio news hitler used
mass media that was how he became hitler
so imagine that we know you are the
average person and there's a handful of
newspapers the newspapers mostly
homogenized to maximize profits so they
may have slightly differing views or
they might be yellow it might be yellow
journalism but for the most part your
information moves slowly so
radicalization is slow along comes radio
which is more rapid it's on you know
frequently and there's multiple channels
with different perspectives now they're
finding new audiences because they have
more opportunity to send out those
messages in real time i wonder if that
played a big role in radicalization
which you know give or take 10 20 30
years results in major clashes in war
yeah it's actually a good thing most
humans don't have time to just live
reading the internet and reading the
news and sifting through the news
disorder they're they're busy working
for a living they're busy raising their
kids and so they they need people to
help them with this fire hose of
information that now comes our way
and yeah i'm sure radio was very similar
i'm sure i know the printing press was
one thing i'll say to bring it full
circle to my conversation about why
conservatives tend not to build the
future it's because yes perhaps the
second world war was a result of radio
perhaps the explosion in in the isms
fascism socialism communism uh anarchism
maybe it was all a result of radio i
think that's a really compelling
theory that you bring up
conservatives did get around to being on
the radio though in 1980 so i just want
to i just want to say after 60 million
people were killed because of radio a
generation later we got some no i i
think it's an interesting point and
conservatives have done a very poor job
keeping up with mass communication with
the artistic fields i mean you look
historically so much of the beautiful
art that we see in the west was
basically commissioned by the catholic
church nowadays i mean what fraction of
media does the catholic church let alone
any group you'd call conservative in
general control it's a very small
proportion and i think part of that
could just be the nature of the way
people who tend to be more quote unquote
progressive are willing to experiment
with new technology you were sort of
discussing the fact that conservative
investors would be less likely to put
money into an app that they can't see a
direct utility in the way a left-wing
person might be capable of i'm not sure
but i also think when we talk about
left-wing people today we're not really
talking about the left wing of 20 years
ago even though they have similar
ideological roots because i think many
of them today wouldn't invest in these
tools healthy society needs a healthy
needs healthy liberals
the reason conservatives don't
conservatives have never made art ever
the catholic church didn't make any art
it bought art from much more liberal
people like michelangelo that
a healthy society has healthy liberals
an unhealthy society has ascendant
leftists wow that's a that's a big
difference
why do we make gargoyles anymore yeah
let's bring it no no no no we should
make some put them around the corner i'm
totally doing it
in large gargoyles we have we have a lot
of work and expansion we're doing i'm
getting gargoyles because you look at
all of these and i'm half kidding about
gargoyles but you look at modern
construction and it's like glass steel
boxes that's right there's no there's no
art or or inspiration and then i'm
thinking about a lot of a lot of
churches and a lot of older buildings
gargoyles and i'm like that sounds kind
of like oh if somebody was the fan of
the lord of the rings they'd be like i'm
building a house i'm going to put a gun
you've got to have tubes out of their
mouth that shoot fire though oh yeah
they're just like at will you can push
them i don't know if that's legal but we
can certainly have it spray water you
just have it shoot electricity you're
more conservative than i thought because
that's a very practical that's not a
non-artistic practical thing that you
just that you just suggested you know
regarding the fire hose of information
you're talking about with the internet i
would love to be able to understand all
the information on the internet without
having to read it or watch it so i'm
thinking of neural link
it's a bit esoteric because it hasn't
come out yet and i wonder if it's like
we invented the fire hose but we don't
have any of the the mechanism to
to control it really or very well very
rudimentary think about how crazy it's
going to be when person has its own
problem so they actually refer to all
the tweets on twitter as the fire hose
you know so if you want to access the
api for certain information or whatever
and some companies do it just like
there's so much information on twitter
i got to tell you they i i would be
willing to bet the the twitter firehouse
has been plugged into an ai a long time
ago and it's like
a calcul it knows everything happening
it's an oracle at this point i should
also specify i don't know if i want to
see everything on the internet because
the mind can get warped by crazy
violence real quick um you through
twitter's information with everyone
posting things
just think about what happens in new
york city when a uh let's say a
transformer explodes instantly you're
going to have 3 000 tweets all saying
i heard this explosion instantly those
with access to the geolocation data are
going to know exactly where all of those
people are instantly the ai is going to
be able to get this circle on a map of
all these people saying they heard an
explosion and then be able to
triangulate where the explosion was
basically based on how many people are
tweeting about it they'll know exactly
where that is
instantly think about anything in that
regard that people might talk about be
it a storm be it a flood
there's going to be ai that has access
to
to this fire host now what happens when
you plug into the metaverse and they can
download that rapid information people
will become like
i don't know man what people will become
but you'll just know everything all at
once and that's that's
it's going to be an experience i'll tell
you you need to see this is funny
because you you made this point earlier
about how it's good that most people
can't just sit online and consume
information all day and
we have this saying right people joke
about going outside and touching grass
it's like all right bro you're too
online there's this idea of being
terminally on the internet to the point
where you just can no longer recognize
and contend with reality and so if
people do get plugged into that point my
goodness i don't even know what
political ideology they'll have because
some 14 year old will spend hours and
hours and hours online and end up in
more and more bizarre esoteric corners
of political
and claim that that's their view this is
happening and i don't know if you're
familiar with this we've talked about it
quite a bit
uh are you familiar with um elsagate no
so this was something that happened
about four or five years ago where
youtube was inundated with people
dressing up like elsa from frozen
spider-man oh yeah joker and then uh so
it was these weird videos with no length
with like no speaking just music and the
joker would chase elsa and spider-man
would save her and it was because
algorithmically those characters
generated a lot of hits and
recommendations
so people made content for children but
this began to devolve eventually the
people who made the content many of
these people realized
it's babies watching this stuff babies
can't change the channel it's the
autoplay feeding the content so they
used computer programs to procedurally
generate content with these keywords you
ended up with videos that were very
bizarre like
there's one video one of the most
notable in this space was
a adolf hitler
but his his body is a woman in a bikini
doing tai chi as
some indian family sings finger family
nursery rhyme
and the incredible hulk is also like you
know doing like some kind of boxing
maneuver the reason was it didn't matter
what the content of the video was it
would it mattered all that matter was
the key words were in it nursery rhyme
finger family the hulk for some reason
hitler i guess these things were
shocking and generated recommendations
children grew up watching this stuff so
when when ian said i'm sorry when
sheamus is talking about their warped
perspective
we are going to have
12 we probably have it now 10 year olds
who are unsupervised on the internet
watching the craziest stuff you've nev
you'll never understand abstract
nonsense of you know the incredible hulk
and hitler dancing together
and when those people grow up they're
going to have insane views that make no
sense because when we grew up we're
older right with shame i think james is
the youngest person yeah maybe i don't
know yeah he's youngest person here 27
so happy birthday my parents had were
living in reality all of our parents
were living in reality even with james
being the youngest person but what about
one of these kids who's 10 years old
today when they have their first kid and
the values they transfer down to those
children are telling the great story of
hitler's female female hitler's tai chi
against the hulk as their as their story
or whatever like these these things are
going to be pro wired into their brain
when i was a little kid with things that
were writing wired into my brain were
superman you know batman star trek the
next generation those values carry
forward if little kids are being are
developing around psychotic algorithmic
nonsense yep they're just going to be
insane i just typed in elsagate too to
get a look and i mean there's some crazy
girl drinking a beer like a baby
drinking a beer with a spiderman yo
there's elsa had had cartoons on youtube
of little kids drinking urine this is
like r-rated contest
uh i actually know someone who told me
that their child came across content on
the internet that was supposed to be
peppa pig
and it was actually peppa pig describing
some extremely violent things and
actually basically telling the kids to
do violent things very disturbing very
disturbing yeah i think one of the
things that's missing in our culture now
is cultural literacy
and it's not a topic that gets discussed
much it probably should be discussed a
lot more that when we were kids the the
western canon that would which a canon
is important because it's essentially
the set of stories and ideas that we all
share
the western canon was baked into all of
the fiction that we ingested so i
learned the the famous story of uh of
tom sawyer convincing his friends to
whitewash the fence right that's right i
learned that from looney tunes i didn't
learn it from reading huck finn you
couldn't you know
a seven-year-old can't read huck finn
but a seven-year-old could watch looney
tunes i learned about classical music
from looney tunes you know
i think that that
that idea that we have a shared heritage
that we have a shared fiction even a
fictional a legendary uh heritage you
know the stories that we all know uh is
completely gone and to your point i i
think we are already seeing the results
of it there's never been a generation
with more psychosis oh yeah than young
people today right i mean i think it's
going to get substantially it's going to
get some people don't worry people
understand
uh i've been kind of obsessed with
talking about the metaverse just because
i've been you know it's this
i i read news i read politics i read
culture and all of these cultural
stories that keep popping up just lead
me to the singularity you know that's
what i think people call it alex jones
calls it that the metaverse is a path
towards this you know unification of men
and machine or whatever ray kurzweil
thing yeah so the one one of the things
i mentioned was that a lot of what we're
experiencing in in in the culture war
with the transgender issue is actually
due to technological advancement now i'm
not making a social commentary on this
i'm making a scientific one
when we isolated hormones
and then in the 1960s started creating
hormone therapies this led to a sort of
understanding of what hormones can do to
the body which leads us to the 90s where
hormone replacement therapy becomes more
popular which results to in the 90s you
now have prominent adults who have
underwent or undergone hormone
replacement therapy
now sharing those ideas and expanding
that idea
again not a social commentary scientific
one if the debate we're having now
because of the existence and the
isolation and creation of hormones and
that technology has resulted in this
cultural war debate what will happen
when we start shifting into
metaverse spaces
when we're plugging our brains in or
virtual reality to go to work already on
twitter many people use cartoon avatars
or animals as their as their profile
picture
what happens if we really do and i think
we will get to that point where we have
our business meetings in a high-res
metaverse and someone shows up to work
and it's tony the tiger or some giant
ostrich
and they and they say you can't
discriminate on me
on how i choose to represent myself in
the metaverse environment thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you